en el último vídeo hable un buen sobre
el factor determinante para cuando
tenemos inflación o deflación y no es
tanto el suministro de dinero aunque el
suministro de dinero tendrá un efecto en
realidad es la capacidad de utilización
ésta estará conducida por la demanda e
hice una distinción porque de un ejemplo
de una isla donde tú podrías tener un
suministro muy pequeño de dinero como
una concha de mar por ejemplo pero si la
velocidad es muy alta la gente lo
expresa en demanda y tendrás una
utilización muy alta de toda la
capacidad en la isla y podrías tener
inflación incluso si los recursos
monetarios son solo una concha por otro
lado digamos que hallamos un montón de
conchas pero todos dejan de hacer
transacciones y la velocidad se reduce
en ese caso aún si los recursos
monetarios son muchos o más que lo que
había antes la gente no lo expresan en
demanda así la demanda será mucho menor
que la capacidad como mostramos en el
vídeo de pasteles cuando tienes una gran
capacidad sin utilizar
es un incentivo para todos el tratar de
vender esas unidades extras y bajarán
los precios así que pueden tener
incrementos en los recursos monetarios y
la velocidad disminuye o si la demanda
se va frenando pero eso pero eso es lo
que está causando que la velocidad
disminuye entonces aún podemos tener una
situación deflacionaria de hecho chícamo
la gráfica donde mostramos esto de cada
salto inflacionario era estimulado
o más bien precedido por un gran repunte
en la capacidad de utilización y la
inflación realmente iniciaba una vez que
la capacidad de utilización entraba en
un rango del 80% podrías imaginarte que
si en promedio el mundo se encuentra en
80% eso significa que algunas personas
están en 70% otras en 90 otras en 95 y
aquellos que están en 95 son quienes
dicen hoy en vez de tratar de correr al
96 98 por ciento de utilización porque
no subir los precios y no preocuparse
por producir más y obviamente sus
ingresos caen en la de otras personas
sus egresos van a los ingresos de otros
en fin así tienes una inflación de
precios generalizada con esto dicho
ahora quiero tocar otro punto al inicio
de los 70 es todo mundo
del impacto del petróleo en 1973 ocurrió
la guerra de yom kipur reabastecidos
israelí ahí tienes a los países de la
opep que esencialmente dejaron de vender
petróleo a eeuu y a muchas otras
naciones occidentales y la gente empezó
a decir que el precio del petróleo se
disparó a los cielos y eso fue lo que
trajo la inflación eso probablemente
contribuyó a ello por en 1973 que está
justo por aquí así que si ves esta
gráfica estamos en el espectro de la
inflación verdad los precios
generalizados fueron incrementando y la
capacidad de utilización que lo precedió
quizás solo agregó leña al fuego con
esto dicho con esto ha dicho la pregunta
que todo el mundo se hace es que va a
ocurrir ahora
así que antes de la crisis financiera
tuvimos cierta cantidad de capacidad
no sé ciertas capacidades
a cierta cantidad de capacidad así que
digamos que todo esto es la producción
estadounidense jaja y en un ambiente
normal digamos que esto es el pibe
estadounidense ok que el pib sólo es la
producción así que en un ambiente normal
como que nos vamos de vuelta a los
sesentas y quizás probablemente debería
tener la gráfica de bloomberg aquí
también porque es bastante interesante
alrededor del 60% del pib fue en consumo
y no no el consumo no siempre no siempre
es algo malo no siempre es algo malo
porque bueno el consumo no siempre es
algo malo de hecho es algo que solemos
hacer para tener un buen nivel de vida
si tengo un bonito sitio en una
televisión y además me voy de vacaciones
es consumo pero mejora nuestro nivel de
vida y el fin de todos los países es
mejorar el nivel promedio de vida pero
el resto es ahorro
en un país tradicionalmente responsable
y desarrollado se ahorra el 40% quizás
entre el 30 y el 40% dependiendo de si
estás en japón o en europa occidental
ahora esencialmente los ahorros se
convierten en inversión para subir la
producción así que los ahorros son lo
que te permite incrementar tu producción
del próximo año
oops
ok déjenos subir así que si te un
ahorras un poquito tu producción va a
disminuir porque nadie va a invertir en
fábricas nadie va a invertir en ellas y
las fábricas se volverán viejas y las
carreteras no se podrán usar y demás
cuando alguien está invirtiendo esto es
el ahorro de alguien más y es muy
importante entender que la inversión y
los ahorros son dos lados de la misma
moneda si nadie ahorra no hay dinero
para invertir pero volviendo al ejemplo
cuando la gente ahorra no solo es lo que
mantiene la producción además incrementa
la producción total para este año la
siguiente década no sé entonces cuando
consumimos 60 por ciento de esto estamos
consumiendo 60 por ciento de un número
grande y nuestro nivel de vida sube y
esta es una situación muy buena y
sustentable lo que pasó
desafortunadamente desde el inicio de
los 80s es que estados unidos tuvo una
constante expansión del crédito empezó a
prestar más y más dinero a todos y otros
países empezaron a prestarle más y más
dinero y la mayor parte de ellos se
expresó en más y más consumo
así que si miras la producción
estadounidense este digamos el pib
el pib
si ahora te vas al 2007 en promedio los
estadounidenses consumían más de lo que
se producía se tenían ahorros negativos
si dibujara eso parecería algo así
déjenme ponerlo así
en 2007 el consumo fue mayor que la
producción total así que la pregunta es
cómo cómo ocurrió eso cómo ocurrió que
el consumo mayor fuera que el consumo
fuera mayor que la producción total
todos hablan del dinero y las divisas
esencialmente eeuu tomó prestada
producción de otros países cuando eeuu
tomó prestado de los chinos a los que
solían comprar sus mercancías
esencialmente toman prestada su
producción cierto tomaron prestado sus
bienes así que cuando les dan una cuenta
en dólares es una promesa que en un
futuro ellos pueden usar esa cuenta para
venir y usar algo de la producción
americana pero en el curso de las
últimas décadas estuvieron tomando
prestado de la producción de otros y se
convirtieron en grandes deudores así
cuando tu consumo es mucho mayor que tu
producción te das cuenta que no es una
situación sustentable y tal vez tomaron
prestado un poco más de dinero y de
hecho ocurrió así que tomaron prestada
la producción de otros también para
impulsar las inversiones no es como que
no hubiera inversiones en los últimos 20
o 30 años se tuvo mucha inversión pero
esencialmente el consumo y la inversión
fueron financiados por la
opción de otras personas eso fue lo que
ocurrió y por supuesto cuando tienes el
consumo tocando contra bueno estás en
una utilización máxima verdad en esta
situación que lo hace un incentivo más
para invertir así que toda esta gente
deseaba invertir en eeuu lo que pasó fue
que te das cuenta de mucho el
financiamiento mucha de la deuda que se
tenía
era facilitada por las por las casas de
la gente los préstamos hipotecarios pero
la gente no es bueno con él no es buena
con eso ahora los bancos se secaron se
fue la liquidez las personas no podían
pedir préstamos así que tenemos una
situación donde una considerable
cantidad de consumo y de hecho una gran
cantidad de desinversión que usaron para
impulsar el gimnasio financiamiento
desaparece ahora que vivimos en un mundo
global deberías pensar en serio sobre la
producción global pero no importa
podríamos hablar sólo de la producción
de eeuu pero ahora esa demanda
desaparece ha desaparecido si esta es la
producción de eeuu digamos que la que
tomaba de china o japón o cualquier otro
lado y nuestro consumo cae hasta aquí no
es porque de repente la gente fuera
prudente es porque las personas dejan de
ir a comprar cosas o no se lo que sea no
pueden conseguir otra tarjeta de crédito
o un préstamo hipotecario así que
tenemos esta situación donde hay una
baja utilización y aquí viene lo que
platicamos en el último vídeo que cuando
tienes una baja utilización es un
incentivo para todos a bajar precios
cuando tienes un buen de casas vacías la
gente baja las rentas
cuando las fábricas de carros están
vacías la gente baja los precios cuando
las personas son subutilizadas los
salarios bajan y puedes ver este shock
recientemente justo aquí como dijimos en
el último vídeo la línea naranja es la
capacidad de utilización de eeuu y bajo
del rango alrededor del 80% bajo de ese
rango si hubiera subido por aquí me
hubiera empezado a preocupar por la
hiperinflación pero cómo ves alrededor
del verano de 2007 cayó de la cima y
anda aquí abajo en algún lugar y como
ves posteriormente la inflación también
cayó así que la dinámica la que estamos
hablando la capacidad de utilización
cayendo porque esencialmente se tiene se
tiene un impacto en la demanda y luego
esto ha conducido a una caída en los
precios así que la pregunta es todo lo
que hace hacienda y la reserva federal
está imprimiendo dinero verdad y obama
está gastando billones de dólares en
estímulos todo eso llevará a la
inflación mi respuesta es que solo hay
que mirar los números de la capacidad de
utilización y como sabrás el plan de
estímulos toda la idea alrededor de ello
es
es en realidad que el gobierno americano
no quiere que entren a una espiral
deflacionaria si el consumo cae así
tenemos esta capacidad y los precios
bajan si los precios bajan un poco no
afecta al comportamiento de la gente en
total pero si la gente empieza a tener
esperanzas que los salarios bajen que
los precios van a bajar todos entran en
pánico y dejan de gastar todos dejan de
gastar digamos que todos dejan de gastar
entonces la utilización se va todavía
más abajo
entonces dejamos de gastar la
utilización baja el desempleo suben más
y esto también hace que el miedo
incremente más el desempleo y el miedo
hacen aunque la gente dejen de gastar
todavía más y este es el ciclo
deflacionario que todos los economistas
y los gobiernos le temen y habrás visto
que durante la gran depresión
déjenme dibujar el punto donde esté el
cero
todo ok
ok aquí está este es el cero
muy bien este es el cero
esta es la línea divisora entre
divisoria entre la inflación y la
deflación ya ves que eeuu ha tenido
episodios distintos de deflación aquí
por ejemplo está justo la depresión la
gran depresión estas después de la
primera guerra mundial y la gran
depresión de hecho duró este tiempo
hasta bueno si se entró a la guerra al
final los treintas justo de aquí aquí de
aquí a que se tuvo aquí la primera ola
por ejemplo del nuevo trato que
realmente nunca llegó a un nivel
significativo de inflación yo en ese
sentido consideraría cualquier cosa
arriba del 5% de inflación como muy muy
mal y déjenme dibujar una línea aquí así
que es la marca del 5% y los americanos
no llegaron arriba arriba del 5% hasta
que terminó la primera guerra mundial
luego tienes aquí el período de
posguerra los acuerdos de bretton woods
y luego en los setentas hubo como hablé
antes el shock del petróleo y el resto
ya es historia pero como ves los
periodos deflacionarios son cosas que
los gobiernos quieren evitar a toda
costa así que la idea de los estímulos
es para que el para el gobierno de pedir
pero estado dinero porque nadie más
puede y esencialmente pueden rellenar
los huecos que los consumidores dejan ok
ahora la pregunta es van a tapar
completamente el hueco muy bueno me doy
cuenta de que me estoy quedando sin
tiempo otra vez no me gusta hacer vídeos
muy largos así que hablaré de ello en el
próximo vídeo